so hello and welcome to another episode
of biographics I'm your host Carl
Smallwood and today we're talking about
Sean Connery the unrepentant Scott and
this suit this is not going to be an
ongoing thing but I just so happen to
own a Tartan suit from a wedding I went
to if we're talking about James Bond
Anna Scotsman it just makes sense and
this video is based on an original
article by Larry holsworth
Sean Connery Rose to Fame in the 1960s
portraying British secret agent James
Bond he became a part of that decade
British Invasion which saw music films
and television programming and fashion
from the United Kingdom of warm cultures
in Europe and North America yet
throughout his long life Connery
recoiled at being called British he was
loudly and proudly a son of Scotland he
called himself a Scot and even wore his
Clan's kill and he was knighted by Queen
Elizabeth II in the year 2000. Connery
was not the first choice to play James
Bond on film and the fictional agent's
Creator Ian Fleming openly disapproved
of the scotsman's casting yeah Connery's
acting talents were such that he had
only won over Fleming but the writer
added portions of Sean's performance
into new stories including his Scottish
Heritage Connery eventually tired of the
role and branched out significantly yeah
he remains the standard against which
subsequent portray as a bond are
measured and personally my favorite bond
is Pierce Brosnan I often think back to
a discussion I had with a friend of mine
where they said well Pierce brosn is the
only Bond where you can believe that you
could be pulling women of that caliber
because look at him and I'll I'll just
never saw pissed yeah Pierce bro that's
Bond that's Bond let us know in the
comments who your bond is in his long
and illustrious career Connery works
with distinguished directors including
John Huston Cindy Lou May and Alfred
Hitchcock he also start opposite many
notes what actresses including tipi
hedron Lana Cerner and Catherine Zeta
Jones to name just a few it was his Bond
movie that actually introduced the Bevy
of actors known to fans and film bosses
Bond girls his film career covered more
than 50 years and led to International
Acclaim yeah he is forever linked with
the Persona he created when he first
uttered the words Bond
James Bond and I can't do Sean Connery's
accent then I am Scottish on my mother's
side I cannot do a Scottish accent
however I would be remiss if I didn't
say my favorite Sean Connery joke that
being when does Sean Connery normally
like to watch Wimbledon tennis
Sean Connery was born in Edinburgh on
August 25th 1930 the first of two sons
born to Joseph Connery and his wife
euphemia McLean Connery as a child he
was called Tommy a name he came to
detest by his mid-teens he insisted upon
being called Sean something that was
helped by the fact he had a friend named
Sheamus so when the two were seen
together in the neighborhood they were
often called Sean and Sheamus and he
found that he preferred the name to
Tommy small as a young child he
experienced a growth spurt in his teens
growing to his adult height of 188
centimeters or six foot two inches tall
in his late teens he worked as a Milkman
in his teens learning the streets of
Edinburgh with a Precision that never
left him he hauled milk cans using
horse-drawn Wagons at 16 he joined the
Royal Navy and celebrate the facts he
had himself tattooed eventually the
actor would bear two tattoos one reading
quite fittingly Scotland forever and the
other quite simply Mom and Dad during
his brief Naval career he trained in
Gunnery and served as an able Seaman
aboard the HMS formidable and aircraft
carrier Connery left the Navy in 1949
after being diagnosed with a genital
ulcer during his Naval service he took
up serious bodybuilding after his
discharge he worked a diverse range of
jobs to say the least a truck driver a
lifeguard and a coffin polisher and new
model for artists his bodybuilding led
him to compete in various contests
including Mr Universe though sources
differ as to when he competed and how he
placed given what he looked like I'm
gonna guess quite highly his fondness
for other athletic activities though
including football eventually led to him
giving up bodybuilding since increased
body mass detracted from his overall
athleticism his football skills were
sufficient to attract an offer to play
professionally with Manchester United an
offer Connor returned down
Connery first came to the theater as a
stagehound attracted by both the pay and
the actresses he met there like he was
already being bombed look at that
skising on women he first appeared on
stage as an extra portraying one of the
Seabees in a London production of South
Pacific he toured with the play
eventually taking over the lead role
formerly portrayed by the American actor
Larry Hagman as the almost stereotypical
struggling new actor he took diverse
roles while working odd jobs outside of
the theater including as a babysitter
while living in the homes of friends or
indeed employers by the late 1950s
Connolly was appearing in small roles in
film and television during this phase of
his career he appeared alongside several
notable actors of the day including
Herbert lome Van Johnson and Patrick
mcguin he slowly graduated into bigger
and bigger roles often playing Tradesmen
due to his Heritage the strong
working-class accent he possessed kind
of like pigeonholed him into certain
roles until he played Bon lies in 1958
he appeared in his first major role
opposite Lana Turner in the film another
time another place his character was
having an affair with the Turner's
character which led to Turner's then
boyfriend a gangster named Johnny
stompanato to assume the actors were
conducting a real-life Affair stompanato
one day visited the set waving a gun and
went off Connery according to most
sources knocking to the floor after
disarming him with a single punch
stompanato was banned from the certain
shortly thereafter left England though
Connery would later report he was
threatened by an Associates of American
mobster Mickey Cohen stompanata was a
known employee of Cohen so the two were
believed to be linked whatever the case
the threats never materialized because
stompanato was later stabbed and killed
by Cheryl crane Lana Turner's own
daughter The Killing was ruled a
justifiable homicide by a Coroner's
inquest by 1961 Connery had appeared in
the lead in several films those reviews
were shall we say lackluster and he
liked the status of the leading man in
both London and Hollywood he was then he
was approached to play the role of James
Bond in the upcoming film doctor now
James Bond's Creator Ian Fleming was not
enthralled by this choice
in his ever popular series of James Bond
novels and short stories Ian Fleming
bestow the Wily British agent with a set
of clearly defined characteristics many
of which were Reflections on his own
tastes such as Bond's fondness for
scrambled eggs he's drinking and he's
Taylor on Seville realm he gave Bond his
own lock and style in Casino Royale the
character of s Berlin describes the
Asian as follows Bond reminds me rather
of hogika Michael he repeats the
reference to the American piano player
and actor in Moonraker describing Bond
as rather like hokikam icon in a way
when Fleming learned of Connery being
favored for the wrong he made a
backhanded reference to the actor
calling him a overdeveloped stuntman
Fleming also used words such as
unrefined in reference to Connery until
on bridge with the actor being a
working-class Scott Connery ever proud
with Scottish Heritage later referenced
Fleming as a real snob and presumably
despite his own misgivings with the
wrong Connery recognized the Boost it
would give to his career and worked hard
to win the ROM he found allies in
producer Kobe broccoli and especially in
broccoli's wife Dan cleaner Fleming
continued to resist the choice even when
his own longtime girlfriend informed in
that Connery presented the sexual
Charisma necessary for the wrong Fleming
and Connery would not physically meet
until filming was underway in Jamaica
where the author resigned her for
several months of the year by then
Connery had created most of the
indelible traits of the British super
agent including a distinctive walk
supposedly taught to him by director
Terence Young and there is a very funny
possibly apothetical story about one of
the ways Sean Connery got the wrongs
when he first walked in and the casting
director saw him they were impressed by
his physique and his stature but not his
mannerisms and it was at the behest of a
producer there they watched him leave
the audition and the story goes is that
they watch Sean Connery walk to his car
which they described as panther-like and
just the way he like you know his eyes
were constantly surveilling the um the
surrounding area and the absolute
confidence with which he carried himself
convinced them that he could be bombed
but he was still nonetheless a diamond
in the rough a diamond they sought to
polish by introducing Connor 22 clubs
and gambling in London tailored
wardrobes and they even had the actor
inject a sense of humor into the
character as an aside it's not really
known who came up with the introduction
Bond James Bond although it's worth
pointing out that in the film he's
actually parroting the character Sylvia
trench who introduced herself as trench
Sylvia trench to which Bond responds in
kind Dr No had the lowest production
budget of any Bond film but Connery had
signed a five film deal when he accepted
the ROM giving him Financial Security
not to know was released in 1962 to
shall we say mixed reviews but immense
success in the box office the follow-up
film from Russia we love released in
1963 cemento Sean Connery as James Bond
in the eyes of fans around the world Ian
Fleming himself eventually warmed the
idea of Connery Bond and in a new Bond
novel released in March 1964 entitled
You Only Live Twice the 11th novel in
the series it's the first to provide any
real background on Bond's early life and
in the novel Fleming gives his hero a
Scottish father and injects more humor
into spawn the most present in earlier
books clearly connory's performance had
impressed the writer at least a little
bit and for anyone who's like you know
watch later Bond movies the Scottish
Heritage of bond is kept in you know
movies in the modern series Fleming
himself did not live to see the third
installment in the bond series
Goldfinger released in 1964 dying just
the month before it was released but
then Connery was already tiring of the
role during lapses in production of the
Bond films he stretched his acting
career in several films working with
other directors and genres one of them
was suspense
when Sean Connery signed his contract
with Eon Productions the producer of the
bond series included him in the roles of
other films besides Bond he was
concerned the successive Bond would
limit the types of roles he was offered
he told Eon Productions that he wanted
to work with Hitchcock and Eon arrange a
meeting with the director
controversially Connery also asked to
see a copy of the script for Marnie
concerned that he'll be a spy suspense
story similar to North by Northwest
another Hitchcock film which has starred
Cary Grant and of course the James Bond
movies themselves when told that not
even Grant had asked for a preview of
the Hitchcock script Connery is said to
have replied I'm not Cary Grant in Mani
Connery played Mark Ruland a wealthy
publishing executive and widower who's
concerned with the title character's
aversion to the color red having
previously stolen money from an employer
and fleeing money applies for work with
his publishing company and draws the
attention of Ruland he later learned her
stealing from his company tracks her
down and blackmails her into marrying
him all the while he struggles to
understand her fear the color red as
well as her sexual frigidity the role
was as unlike James on as it could
possibly be and the film Drew mixed
reviews with many panning both Connery
and his co-star to be hedra the New
Yorker called it and I quote a trashy
movie with two terrible performances in
the leading roles the New York Times
referred to Connery and hedron as
relative newcomers the film has earned a
more laudable reputation over the years
and it made a profit at the box office
but it was hardly a rousing success for
either Connery or Hitchcock the same
year in 1964 Connery played the lead
role in woman of straw with Gina Laurita
and Ralph Richardson it too Drew
scathing reviews with one critic Eugene
Archer of the New York Times referring
to it as a hapless British film 1964
also saw the release of Goldfinger
though followed the following year by
Thunderball Connery continued to cast
about for roles outside of the James
Bond genre in 1965's the hill directed
by Sydney lumay a film about a military
prison it featured Connery in the
leading role won numerous Awards and was
a box office flop so a reversal of
Fortunes in the worst possible way for
an act on like to make money another
flop featured Connery in 1966 a fine map
nurse in which he played a poet with
writer's block in 1967 Connery went to
Japan for the filming of You Only Live
Twice well then it was announced this
will be his final Bond film he was tired
of the wrong one also of the
international recognition of Sean
Connery as James Bond he'd also creates
some controversy regarding his personal
views
in November 1965 Sean Connery then at
the height of his popularity and with
Bon Mania rampant he gave an interview
to Playboy magazine the interview was
part of the pre-release publicity for
the highly anticipated Thunderball
during the interview Playboy quote what
Connery as having said and I quote and I
sure hope this doesn't get taken out of
context
um on my social media accounts I don't
think there is anything particularly
wrong with hitting a woman but I don't
recommend you do it in the same way you
hit a man Connery later denied he had
made the remarks claiming he was taken
out of context nonetheless they remained
a part of his Persona and dogged him for
years in 1985 when the James Bond in the
60s was long behind him he appeared for
an interview with Barbara Walters when
Walters brought the remarks made to
Playboy Connery was unrepentant indeed
he Amplified his early remarks saying
again I haven't changed my opinion
adding that it depends entirely on the
circumstances after explaining that
hitting a woman should only be done as a
last resort he told Walters women are
pretty good at this they can't leave it
alone
yeah they don't they want to have the
the last word and you give them the last
last word but they're not happy with the
last one they want to say it again
and and get into a really provocative
situation
then
I think it's absolutely right it being
absolutely right in this situation
meaning hitting the woman at the time of
the Playboy interview Connery was
married to his first wife Diane celenzo
an actress who appeared uncredited in
several swimming scenes in Thunderball
they divorced in 1973 in 2006 Cilento
released her autobiography in which she
alleged both physical and mental abuse
were part of a marriage to Sean rumors
of such abuse had Arisen earlier in
their marriage which Connery had always
denied while solento had remained silent
Connery was a long time supporter of the
Scottish national party which supports
Scottish independence and withdrawal
from the United Kingdom when solento's
allegations surfaced in 2006 coupled
with the earlier comments to Playboy and
Barbara Walters he was forced to cancel
a scheduled address before the Scottish
Parliament he issued a statement through
friends saying in part I don't believe
that any level of abuse towards women is
ever Justified under any circumstance
yes he's previously expressed views
continued to Halt him and dogged him for
the rest of his days
thank you
Connery returned to the role of James
Bond in 1971's diamonds are forever
because he was offered a then record
1.25 million dollars for the wrong the
film is generally guarded as one of the
worst in the entire Bond franchise which
is impressive consuming some of the
other films in the bond franchise and
easily his worst performance in the role
from then on he put James Bond behind
him that is until 1983 when he accepted
the role in a non-eon production remake
A Thunderball titled Never Say Never
Again the title was supposedly a
reference to Conroy's dismissal of bond
following diamonds are forever I
personally as well ascribe to the theory
that the rock starring Sean Connery and
Nicholas Cage is an unauthorized Bond
Sequel and that's Sean Connery's
character in that is James Bond after
being disavowed by his government like
if you're not familiar with the film or
the theory I highly recommend going to
watch the rock with that in mind it
really does change your opinion and
perspective on it it's also just a great
film where Nicholas Cage steals a
Lamborghini and drives around like a
madman it's just classic age also I
think Michael Bay directed it so you
know you're in for a good time now in
between his final two Bond film Connery
reached out as an actor and the roles he
agreed to play he betrayed an aging
Robin Hood in Robin and Marion opposite
Audrey Hepburn to critical praise he
then worked with longtime friend Michael
Kane as British adventurers in Tibet the
man who would be king another project
that earned him praise was the wind and
the lion in which he played a Moroccan
brigand called mulai Ahmed al-rasuni yes
Scottish actor Sean Connery played a
Moroccan guy called mulai Ahmed
we did say he had a diverse range of
rocks so what is it with like you go
back to like the 80s and you just have
actors who just like why is it like John
Wayne as Genghis Khan
so yeah and he doesn't change his accent
it's like how how did he get that wrong
it's like oh yes hello Pilgrim I'm
Genghis Khan during the 70s and 80s
Connery averaged around two to three
films per year shooting in locations all
over the world and apparently playing an
all manner of colorful characters he had
a major hit in Europe with the name of
the Rose in 1986. though the film did
not perform well in North America
another film which did resonate with
American audiences was 1987 as The
Untouchables for his role as Chicago
police officer Jimmy Malone he was
awarded the Academy Award for best
supporting actor in 1990 he appeared as
the Lithuanian Captain and the defecting
Soviet submarine in the haunt for Red
October another hit at the box office
despite his inability to affect any
accent other than his native Scottish
one and I think the only film where it's
more jarring that the actor in the film
does not affect an accent that is in
keeping with the character they're
playing is Valkyrie starring Tom Cruise
in which he plays the guy who tries to
assassinate Hitler like a bomb in his
briefcase and Tom Cruise is just Tom
Cruise in that movie and there's a
really great interview with the
producers where they were asked well you
know this film set in like Nazi era
Germany why are none of the actors like
affecting German accents so it's the
producers responded well you know if the
film was realistic that I'll be speaking
German so German accents will be
distracting well then every actor at set
Tom Cruise affects a German accent which
leaves me to believe that Tom Cruise
just couldn't do it uh similar sight
Howard I just don't think Sean Connery
could affect a Lithuanian accent anyway
way acting ability aside his enduring
popularity was such that People magazine
named Connery the sexiest man alive in
1989. he was at the time 59 years old he
continued his Torrid Pace into the 1990s
staying busy with films into the 21st
century his final live-action film
appearance was in 2003's the League of
Extraordinary Gentlemen in which he
played Alan Quartermaine though critics
largely found the film it was another
financial success and there is the
infamous story that Sean Connery quit
acting after appearing in the League of
Extraordinary Gentlemen because it was
just the experience of work and it was
so bad and another fun story about how
he came to accept that role was that he
turned down the wrong with Gandalf in
Lord of the Rings because he didn't
understand it and he made a point of
okay the next film I get an offer for
that I don't understand and to accept it
without reservation and that film was
the league of a shortening gentleman and
he was so like shaken by The Experience
like you know what I don't need I
don't need to act anymore
the game of golf was invented in
Scotland and as a proud Scotsman Sean
Connery loved the game he grew up near
bruntsfield links one of the world's
oldest golf courses though as a youth
his interests leaned towards football
and swimming he had played golf before
Goldfinger though admittedly quite
sporadically when it became apparent
that you would need to appear Adept at
the game for the film Goldfinger he
taught lessons and quickly grew to love
the game he became skilled enough of the
game by the late 1960s of playing in
Prime Events Club tournaments and
alongside numerous notable individuals
including Jack Nicholas Lee Trevino
three-time formion world champion Jackie
Stewart Ben Crosby and many many others
in the 1990s Sean Connery lived
primarily in the Bahamas near life okay
with his second wife there he played
golf almost daily especially following
his retirement from acting he also
played renowned courses around the world
including Saint Andrews and the Royal
Troon in the United Kingdom in his
autobiography fittingly titled being a
Scot released in 2008 Connery summed up
his feelings about the game of golf
stating and I quote I began to see golf
as a metaphor for living for in golf
you're basically on your round competing
against yourself and always trying to do
better if you cheat you'll be the loser
because you're cheating yourself
he then summed up his views on religion
over the years golfers taught me much
and its implicit codes of conduct
provided me with the nearest I've ever
come to religion
in the later years of his career Sean
Connery's loss of hair was obvious what
is little known today though is that
Sean Connery was balding even before he
became James Bond and had it been widely
known it's likely that this would have
been added to the long list of
objections that Ian Fleming had to Sean
Connery taking the role as early as Dr
now Connery appeared in the role of bond
wearing a hairpiece reportedly the hair
pieces grew larger as the film Cannon
expanded and Connor his own hairline
receded to protect the image of James
Bond in the early to mid 1960s Connery
wore a hairpiece for all public
appearances when he performed the role
of Mike rouland in Marnie he again
donned the hairpiece Leicester film
grade public learned that James Bond was
going bold as he grew apart from the
wrong his receding hairline was far less
of a concern his Robin Hood for example
was clearly losing his hair as was his
character in the man who would be king
in the Wind of a lion his hairline was
concealed for the most part by the
costume he wore which I'm going to
imagine was just very Tastefully handled
given the character he played in that
role His Image while portraying Bond was
similar to that for character Luke cool
and always ready with a quick quip the
right wine and the perfect Martini so
they'll roast suits fast cars and
gambling were part of his image
reinforced by the publicity arms at the
studio in truth Sean Connery was quite
shy and it despised the public
perception of him and James Bond has
been won in the same and he largely
avoided the Limelight and parties of
Hollywood this said he did get his bond
on between his marriages dating several
high-profile women including Lana Ward
and Jill St John both of whom appeared
on film with him although women linked
romanticlist Connery include Diane
Cannon the former wife of the
aforementioned Carrie Grant his first
marriage to Dan cilenzo led to the birth
of a son Jason his second marriage was
to Micheline Rock Broome in 1975 so whom
he remain married until the end of his
life a tax Exile from Scotland he lived
in the south of France in the 1980s only
an entire estate there he relocated to
the Bahamas in the 1990s and remained
there as his primary residence following
his retirement from acting in 2006.
[Music]
throughout his career and indeed his
retirement Sean Connery was a staunch
supporter of Scottish independence he
helped fund several events and made
appearances aimed against his support
for separation of Scotland from the
United Kingdom though his status as a
tax Exile limited the time he could
spend in his native country he also
provided endless fodder for those
opposing such an action to their
criticism Conor responded that he was
not living at a tax Exile citing the
vast amounts of taxes he paid numbering
the millions of pounds during the Apex
of his career in the late 1990s he sold
a villa he had owned in Spain raising
additional tax problems with the Spanish
government who was eventually cleared
his tax issues and political views kept
him from receiving a Knighthood in the
views of his supporters that speculation
ended when he was indeed knighted by
Queen Elizabeth II in the year 2000 the
Kilts he wore to appear before her
majesty was of the McLean Clan from
which his mother had descended the
following year the British Parliament
passed a law prohibiting political
contributions from outside the United
Kingdom bringing an end to Conroy's
financial support of the Scottish
national party yet he was not silenced
he continued to argue for Scottish
independence there was the 2010s war on
his health began to fail in his public
appearances were far less frequent in
2020 Sean Connery and his wife were
photographed in the Bahamas they
celebrated their 45th wedding
anniversary by then the actor was
battling dementia as well as heart
failure and other respiratory problems
public appearances were very rare and he
seldom left the gay community of Life at
King October 31st 2020 Connery died in
his sleep at home at the age of 90. and
the always obituaries referred to him as
James Bond in their headlines after this
his body was cremated and plans were
made to scatter the ashes in the Bahamas
and Scotland the place where he called
home and the place where he was born
covert delayed these plans until 2022.
according to his son Jason one site
selected in Scotland was Saint Andrews
home of the RNA Trust Company Limited
which shared with the United States Golf
Association the code of the rules of
golf Sean likely would have approved so
thank you for tuning in to this episode
of biographics and note at the start
I've been your host Carl Smallwood I
promise I won't do this again like you
know I feel awkward I look awkward it
was just a thing I was trying I'll not
do it next time also as mentioned this
video is based on original article by
Larry holsworth they provided any um
Social Links for us that we found below
alongside my own also link below will be
links to our sister channels Geographics
and top tens which I'm also the interim
host for as well as my personal channels
vaccine with Carl Smallwood and Wiki
weekends otherwise if you enjoyed the
video leave a like if you have something
to say about it leave a comment right
now let us know your favorite Bond movie
and if it's not a Pierce Brosnan one
explain why you're wrong also you know
if you want to see more videos on this
subscribe and as always have the day you
deserve
James Bond a drink it's refreshing your
drink Governor anyway cheers everyone
for watching and I hope you have a nice
day